-We're hanging out
with an incredible actor.
Jonah Hill right here. I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The new movie is called
"Don't Look Up."
It's in theaters on Friday.
And on -- on Netflix
December 24th.
Can you talk about
what this movie is about?
It's very funny, by the way,
but it's -- it's --
It's very, like, smart funny,
I think, to me, like --
-Yeah. It's -- It --
So, Adam McKay made this movie,
and Leonardo DiCaprio
and Jennifer Lawrence
play scientists who see a comet
coming to destroy Earth.
And the world's gonna end
in like six months.
So they take it all the way up
to the president,
who is played by Meryl Streep,
and I'm her son
and chief of staff, Jason.
And -- And we deny
the comet's existence.
So, Adam is a brilliant guy.
And he's kind of
very satirically
dealing with some of these
issues that have been massive,
where it's kind of
denial of science, let's say.
Um, and so I play, like,
this kind of spoiled rich kid
who is the son of the president
who is a chief of staff.
And one of the things
I found fun --
You wanna show the picture?
-I do wanna show the picture
'cause I wanna show
your character.
Here's your character right here
holding a purse.
-Yeah, he's a little bitchy
prince. That's how I would --
-That's your mother.
-Meryl Streep.
And those are the nerd,
like, astronomers behind us.
That's what Jason would say,
not me.
But -- So one of the things was
they're like, "Okay, well..."
Let's just say there was
a dynamic, at the time,
where there was a high-up
political figure who perhaps
inappropriately sexualized
his daughter.
I'm not gonna name names.
-Okay. Yeah.
-So my thought was,
"Well, oh, I'm the son.
And most rich kids
look up to their father.
I'm gonna be someone who
worships, like, the mother."
So I thought it'd be interesting
to play on that
as to inappropriately sexualize
my mother in the role.
And then also
since he admires the feminine,
my first thought was he's gotta
have a Birkin bag.
[ Laughter ]
And the other thing was
I wanted to make if
Fyre Festival was a person.
That was sort of my ideology
of it, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
If Fyre Festival was a person.
-Yeah.
-That's who you're playing
in "Don't Look Up."
But how cool was it to act
opposite Meryl Streep?
-It's so cool.
And she's so cool.
And everyone goes on talk shows
and you're like,
"This person's cool.
That person's cool."
Meryl Streep's actually cool.
And she's the best actor.
In fact, I've been -- So, we've
been doing press for this movie,
and in the interviews the past
couple days, I keep saying,
"Oh, and, you know, getting to
work with Meryl, she's the GOAT.
She's the GOAT, right?"
Which, if you know, stands for
Greatest Of All Time, right?
That's, like, an acronym
that you use for, like,
Michael Jordan
or Jay-Z or whoever,
or, you know, whoever your GOAT
is for whatever you're into.
-Yeah.
-And Meryl to me is the GOAT.
She's the greatest of all time.
So the whole week, I'm saying,
"You know,
working with Meryl is the best.
She's the GOAT.
She's the GOAT."
And then today, we're doing a
press conference and she's like,
"You know, and Jonah
is so comfortable with me,
he's been calling me
a goat all week."
And -- And she's like --
And I'm like,
"What the [bleep]?"
And I'm like -- I'm like --
And Jennifer Lawrence
explained to her.
'Cause she was telling Jennifer
about this.
How she -- And she's so cool,
she wasn't even offended by it.
She was just like,
"I guess he, like, loves me
and is calling me a goat."
And -- And Jennifer's like,
"No, Meryl.
It stands for
Greatest Of All Time."
So she was like, "Hey, thanks
for calling me the GOAT.
I thought you were calling me
a goat this whole time."
And I was like,
"Meryl, you're, like,
the greatest of all time."
-And she's still cool about it.
Yeah, she really is.
Meryl Streep.
-Shout-out to the GOAT!
Yeah.
-The greatest of all time.
It's very good.
It's very well-written,
very well-acted,
very well-directed.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's our pal Jonah Hill
in "Don't Look Up."
Take a look at this.
-Dr. Randall, you are now
the chief science adviser
to the White House.
-What?
-And as such,
we need you to attend
an emergency cabinet meeting
where you will be
fully debriefed.
-What about us?
-You do not have clearance
for this, sweetheart.
Don't trip. Got you
some crackers, some waters.
-You don't need to throw it
on the floor.
-It's going to be three,
four hours, tops.
-Here, Kate. I don't know
why he's doing that.
-What if we have to go
to the bathroom?
-We'll lay out some newspaper
for you,
grab you a can of Febreze.
-Hey. Short, sweet,
and simple science.
-I'll be back.
-Science tells the truth,
Randall.
-You want to come?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What a jerk!
-Yo, real quick.
Before we end,
I'm not a political man.
But I do believe
in climate change,
and my girlfriend will kill me
if I don't read this.
I just will say I don't know
how to deal with this stuff.
It feels like Mt. Everest.
You can call or e-mail
your congressperson
and ask them to support
H.R. 794,
the National Climate
Change Emergency.
That's it. Very easy.
If you're into it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're welcome any time, buddy.
I love you.
-Thank you, bro. Thank you.
-Jonah Hill, everybody.